there's an algorithm called momentum or
gradient descent with momentum that
almost always works faster than the
standard gradient descent algorithm in
one sentence the basic idea is to
compute an exponentially weighted
average of your gradients and then they
use that gradient update your ways
instead in this video let's unpack that
one sentence description and see how you
can actually implement this as the most
of an example let's say that you're
trying to optimize a cost function which
has contours like this so the red dots
denote the position of the minimum maybe
you start a gradient descent here and if
you take one iteration of gradient
descent either Batchelor mini-batch
mendes and maybe end up heading there
but now you're on the other side of this
ellipse you kind of if you take another
step of green descent maybe end up doing
that and then another step another step
and so on and you see that gradient
descent will you know sort of take a lot
of steps right just slowly oscillate
towards the minimum and these
up-and-down oscillations slows down
gradient descent and prevents you from
using a much larger learning rate in
particular if you were to use a much
larger learning rate you might end up
overshooting and then that diverging
like so and so the need to prevent the
oscillations are getting too big forces
you to use the learning rate as not
itself too much another way of viewing
this problem is that on the vertical
axis you once you're learning to be a
bit slower because you don't want those
oscillations but on the horizontal axis
you want to faster learning right
because you wanted to aggressively move
from left to right or that minimum - or
that very thought so here's what you can
do if you implement gradient descent
with momentum
on each iteration or more specifically
drink elevation tea you would compute
the usual derivatives DWD be I omit the
superscript square bracket else but you
compute DWD beyond the current
mini-batch and we're using bash Korean
descent then you know the current
mini-batch would be just your whole
batch and this works as well of a batch
gradient descent so if you're currently
me batches your entire training set this
works fine as well and then what you do
is you compute V D W to be beta v DW
plus 1 minus beta DW so this is similar
to when we're previously computing V
theta equals beta V theta plus 1 minus
beta theta T right so it's computing a
moving average of the derivatives for W
you're getting and then you similarly
compute V DP equals that plus 1 minus
beta times DB and then you would update
your weights using W J's updated as W
minus or learning rate times instead of
updating it with DW with the derivative
you would updated with v DW and
similarly B of J's updated as B minus
alpha times V DB so what this does is
smooth out the steps of gradient descent
for example let's say the last few
derivatives you computer were this this
this this this if you average out these
gradients you find that the oscillations
in the vertical direction will tend to
average out to something close to the
zero so in the vertical direction where
you want to slow things down this will
average out positive negative numbers so
the average should be close to zero
whereas on the horizontal direction all
the derivatives are pointing to the
right and horizont
direction so the average in a horizontal
direction will still be prepaid so
that's why with this algorithm with a
few innovations you find that the
de-rating dissembled momentum ends up
eventually just taking steps that are
much smaller oscillations in a vertical
direction
but are more directed to what the
horizontal to just moving quickly in the
horizontal direction and so this allows
your algorithm to you know take a more
straightforward path or less to damp out
the oscillations in its path to the
minimum one intuition for this momentum
which works for some people and not for
everyone is that if you kind of minimize
you know a bowl shape function right
this is really the contours of a bowl
because I'm not very good at drawing
they trying to minimize this type of
shape function then these derivative
terms you can think of as providing
acceleration to a ball that you're
rolling downhill and these momentum
terms you can think of as representing
the velocity and so imagine that you're
a bowl and you take a ball and the
derivative in pause acceleration to this
little ball the little ball is rolling
down this hill right and so it rolls
faster and faster because of a
celebration and beta because this number
a little bit less than one this plays a
row of friction and it prevents your
ball from you know speeding up without
limit but so rather than on gradient
descent just taking every single step
independently of all previous steps now
your little ball can roll downhill and
gain momentum is going to sell rate down
this bowl and therefore gain momentum I
find that this ball rolling down the
bowl analogy it seems to work for some
people who enjoy physics intuitions but
it doesn't work for everyone so if this
analogy of a ball rolling down a bowl
doesn't work for you don't worry about
it finally let's look at some details on
how you implement this here's the
algorithm and so you now have to
Hyper parameters the learning rate alpha
as well as this parameter beta which
controls your exponentially weighted
average the most common value for beta
is 0.9 we're averaging over the last 10
days temperature so this is like
averaging or the last 10 iterations
gradients and in practice beta equals
0.9 works very well feel free to try
different values and do some hyper
parameter search but 0.9 appears to be a
pretty robust value well in the how
about bias correction right so do you
want to take vvw and BTB and divide it
by 1 minus beta to the T in practice
people don't usually do this because
after just 10 iterations your moving
average will have warmed up and there's
no longer a bias estimate so in practice
I don't really see people bothering with
bias correction when implementing
gradient descent or momentum and of
course this process is initialize of a
bTW equals 0 note that this is a matrix
of zeros or the same dimension as DW
which is the same dimension as W and B
DB is also initialized to a vector of 0
so the same dimension as DB which in
terms of the same dimensions as B
finally as you mentioned that if you
read the literature on gradient descent
with momentum often you see it with this
term omitted which is 1 minus beta term
omitted so you end up with VD w equals
beta v DW plus DW and the net effect of
using this version in purple is that v
DW ends up being scaled by a factor of 1
minus beta a really 1 over 1 minus beta
and so when you're performing these
gradient descent update alpha just needs
to change by corresponding value of a 1
over 1 minus beta in practice both of
these will work just fine it just
effects um what's the best value of the
learning rate alpha but I find that this
particular formulation is a little less
intuitive because one impact of this is
the end up tuning the hyper parameter
beta then the
Effects of scaling of bTW and VDB as
well and so you end up meeting to retune
the learning rate alpha as well maybe so
I personally prefer the formulations
that I've written here on the left
rather than leaving out the 1 minus beta
term that I tend to use the formula on
the left the printer formula with the 1
minus beta term but for both versions
having beta equals 0.9 there's a common
choice of hyper parameter
it's just that alpha the learning rate
will need to be tuned differently for
these two different versions so that's
it for gradient descent Wolfe momentum
this will almost always work better than
the straightforward gradient descent
algorithm without momentum but there's
no other things we could do to speed up
your learning algorithm let's continue
talking about these in the next couple
videos